this is a young African willoughby's but
this isn't a story about wildebeest
it's a story about what's trying to eat
the wildebeest
the mighty Nile crocodile didn't work
the first time so the croc gives up
kidding kidding I'm kidding that's me
pulling your leg of course the Frog
tries again but will the beasts have
good reflexes and all the Crockett's is
a bloody snap but the wildebeests need
water to survive and the croc is still
hungry the croc will not be denied it
did not live the dinosaurs by giving up
after one try
the crocodile eats mostly fish bud we'll
take a crack at just about anything
Turtles impalas bamboos humans even this
heron it'll even pursue the poor tiny
helpless carmine bee-eaters chase that
have fallen out of their nest
not much sport here but help a snack is
a snack
of course it lives to go after bigger
snacks like a Thompson's gazelle the
crocodile has been on the planet for 200
million years it has the most highly
developed brain and heart of all
reptiles to go with its highly developed
stalking abilities when there's not
enough to go around
the Crocs start battling each other with
the biggest one getting the happy meal
Nile Crocs live mostly in the rivers
marshes and lakes throughout Africa the
hotter the weather the more animals have
to come down for a drink these zebras
land across this watering hole
when the Crocs attack a mighty melee
ensues rocks themselves might get
trampled
a croc attacks Mzee bruh struggles
just when it seems that all is lost the
zebra somehow wriggles away and swims
the safety
the croc then manages to get a hold of a
bulls lake
the bull is desperate to get away that
even tries to bite the Crocs armor but
one zebra is enough to feed several
hungry crocodiles and the frenzy is on
no time to mourn the zebras must rush
past the feeding crocs to make it across
the river